how have you managed to balance your
career and your family life i have six
kids so i just pay attention to the
priorities meaning you know squeaky
wheel gets the grease i've went three
months where my business was the most
important thing i had to deal with
family life was was fine i don't think
your kids want to spend as much time
with you as you think they do if you
give quality time while you're there
everything's going to work out i see
these guys you know they're so worried
about their family that they're broke
you know oh i i have to spend quality
time with my kids it's going to mean
something when they grow up i i don't
think so my dad didn't spend a lot of
time with me our relationship was fine
but when i got a little older he
couldn't help me he was broke so look at
the people that are spending all this
time with their kids raising wonderful
kids but they're broke if my kids had
something where i had to go home and pay
attention to them for three months six
months straight i'm gonna do that other
than that it's just priorities